War is inevitable, one must destroy
in order to create.
We are no jedi
So I started hearing whispers
of Thrawn's return as heir to the Empire.
What happens when you've been thrown out,
such as you've never dreamed?
I've spent most of my life fighting a war.
That's
why I'm trying to convince you to help me
prevent another one.
You and I both know
I could help you with this.
She's still just as stubborn as ever.
I bet your master found
you difficult at times,
and I never got to finish my training.
I walked away from her
just like I walked away from Sabine.
You never made things easy for me,
master.
As a Jedi.
Sometimes you have to make
the decision no one else can.
I'm counting on you to see this through
this haircut.
Sometimes we have to do what's right,
regardless of our personal feelings.
Buckle up.
If we don't stop throwing,
everything will be in vain.
You have no power,
I think.
And spoke highly of you.
I'm not here to discuss my past,
but we have a lot of work to do.
Once a rebel, always a rebel.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a brand new Ahsoka Trailer,
a whole bunch of Star Wars Easter Eggs
that will break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
They also just announced
they're releasing the first two episodes
on the same day, but it's an eight episode
series, so the rest of the episodes
will be weekly like The Mandalorian.
just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage and working our way
through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments.
They start with the voiceover from Ray
Stevenson R.I.P.
May he rest in peace.
He passed away just recently his Baylan Skoll character talking to his apprentice
Shin Hati about the necessity of war
like wars inevitable.
It's going to happen.
that's probably meant to be a larger
conversation about the war that's coming,
that Thrawn is bringing the heir
to the Empire, who they also referenced
several times and show us during the trip
like a full on shot at Thrawn.
lot of big
name drops happening in this trailer.
Like we also get a bunch of Anakin
Skywalker coming from Ahsoka,
making the possibility of his cameo
seen as a force ghost or a flashback
way, way higher.
He is listed on the IMDB,
but I'll talk about that
when we get to that part of the trailer.
based on the way they cut the beginning
of the trailer. Here.
They make it seem like this
ship is heading towards a Republic ship
or New Republic
ship is Baylan Skoll's ship.
he boards the New Republic ship
for some reason attacking
and it seems like ship not is with him
because he's also attacking
a bunch of people on the bridge
that same ship
that's part of the scene of him going full
Darth Vader hallway scene in Rogue One
and Luke Skywalker during The Mandalorian
on all these rebels.
but the difference being that
his lightsaber, as Dave Filoni said,
is purposefully meant to be more orange
than full sith red,
the way they explained his backstory
is that before the events of this series
is a Jedi that survived order 66
and turned into a mercenary
and within the context
of the Ahsoka series, because they're doing
this based on the heir to the Empire
Thrawn trilogy of books.
He's sort of taking the place
of the jurors
Kibo, a Jedi master character
that Thrawn winds up working with.
Hathi is just another force
sensitive person
who's become his apprentice
since Order 66,
but she would have been a child
at that time
when he talks about the need to destroy
in order to create.
They're probably talking
about destroying the New Republic
and allying with Thrawn
so that he will destroy the New Republic.
but I think part of the idea is that he
doesn't want everything that Thrawn wants.
Like Thrawn wants to bring the Empire
back.
Baylan Skoll
has this completely different goal
that he's using Thrawn for.
Like Thrawn is using him
and he's using Thrawn.
more like the enemy of my enemy
is my friend kind of situation.
So it's not like he and Shin Hati
necessarily like Thrawn.
we get a longer version of the scene
from Ahsoka in the last trailer
where she's in that Jedi temple
looking at one of the carvings,
talking about Thrawn
coming back as heir to the Empire.
those are meant to be
a couple of different scenes
sort of stitched together though.
the Jedi Temple that she's in
is meant to be different
from the one that Baylan Skoll is in.
Later this Jedi temple
that she's in the underground ruins
of is part of the action scene
at the beginning of the last trailer
she does wind up fighting
some of Thrawn's H.K.
droids there, though.
So some of Thrawn's people are there.
we see the same shot of Thrawn
on one of his new ships that he's found
while he's in the unknown regions.
there was a whole subplot
during the original Thrawn trilogy
of books, The Heir to the Empire Trilogy,
where he finds his fleet of ships.
This could be part of that storyline
that they're adapting His forces,
before he jumped into the unknown
regions were called the Seventh Fleet.
But it's possible that he lost some
of those ships and then replenish them
and made his forces larger
with other ships from the unknown regions.
this is part of the larger action scene
that Ahsoka has with Baylan Skoll
with their big lightsaber fight,
but it looks like they're using the force
to try and find Thrawn specifically
and it seems like his minion
from the Mandalorian series, Morgan
Elsbeth has found a way
to actually locate him or contact him.
I'm guessing the ship in the background
is either Baylan Skoll's ship or it's Morgan
Elsbeth's ship.
we saw that ship in particular
in the previous trailer
when Baylan Skoll starts
talking about power,
I think he's talking about something
completely different.
I think he might be looking for the world
between worlds
talk about Jedi time travel.
Like I think he's just using Thrawn
and Thrawn is using him.
But one of the big things is that
Thrawn was trying to help his people,
that she ships
and they had trouble
navigating through hyperspace
because you can't really do that
in the unknown regions the same way.
Thrawn had been looking for
for sensitive people to help his people
navigate through hyperspace So.
His bargaining with Baylan Skoll
could have something to do with that.
based on the extra context.
Now it seems like
this is a new Republic fleet where you see
Hera addressing the New Republic Senate.
the war that she's talking about spending
most of her life fighting
is the rebellion.
The events of the original trilogy.
her name is General Hera.
She became a general in the rebellion.
we get into the scene of Chopper with her.
I'm sure we'll get more scenes with him
in future trailers.
My mama comes back.
Seems like she's going to be in
at least a couple of episodes,
or maybe just one episode
Then when Ahsoka comes back
to visit with her
and they talk about going to get Sabine
Ren for help,
I think this is meant to take place
during the time jump
at the end of Star Wars
Rebels like it takes place right
before the events of the original trilogy.
Then you jump to this live action moment
that they feature later in the trailer.
we think this scene is meant to explain
what she was doing before she came back
to Lothal to pick up Sabine
at the end of Rebels.
in probably one of the big revelations
of the trailer here is that Sabine
was training as a Jedi, as the apprentice
to Ahsoka, confirming
that she is for sensitive.
I always assumed she was during rebels,
but they never specifically stated
that likes to use the darksaber.
She's used other lightsabers before.
the reason why she has Ezra's light
saber during this trailer is because Ezra
left the light saber with Chopper
when he took off
into the unknown regions
with the space wheels
And she just kept chopper with her on low
at all.
the reason why she stayed on Lothal
and Ahsoka took off is
because she made a promise to Ezra Bridger
to protect Lothal in his absence.
we get another Anakin
Skywalker named right there.
There's so many.
Anakin Skywalker name drops,
don't you feel now
like there's going to be a Force ghost?
And again, cameo seen during the series
this thing in particular
is basically Ahsoka
recapping the events of Star
Wars, the Clone Wars, and how she left
the Jedi Order, how she stopped
being an ICANN's apprentice officially,
even though she left the Jedi Order
and she technically wasn't
his Padawan anymore,
they still felt very close.
that's why the events of Revenge
of the Sith and his fall to the dark side
were so gut wrenching to her order
66 to be like your best friend
turning into the world's worst person
this scene of them talking about
being master and apprentice make it seem
like they're actually back on the ghost
Pretty much the entire crew of the ghost
is coming back from Star Wars
rebels like we saw Zeb
during the Mandalorian series.
The scene of Sabine on the Speeder
Bike is also very similar to the scene of
Ahsoka coming back after her long absence
during the Clone Wars.
we get a longer scene of Sabine
listening to the hollow recording of Ezra
talking about becoming a Jedi Knight
and even though
they didn't have conversations about it
during the events of Star Wars rebels,
it sounds like at least off screen
they had conversations or Ezra
expected her to train in the force
and become a Jedi Knight at some point.
Otherwise, why would he have made
this hollow recording for
and it seems like this explains why
she cuts her hair because she goes back
on the mission with Ahsoka
and becomes her Padawan officially again.
Like they start their training again.
there was also the line from David Tennant
Jedi Droid in the previous Tenebrae said
Perhaps it's time to begin again
and it's kind of meant
to be a generalization
about a bunch of different characters.
Sabine beginning to again
become a Jedi Knight.
Then they essentially do a live action
version of the very end of Star Wars
rebels with Ahsoka coming
to get her in front of the mural here.
Exact same scene.
it if you didn't watch Star wars rebels
the mural behind her is her art style.
But it's done in the art style of Star
Wars.
Rebels, like all the characters,
look like they did during rebels.
But it's Sabine Wren
who did all this art herself.
that's why all of her mandalorian armor
because she is
a mandalorian is graffitied
in her own art style.
one of the weirder things
about The Mandalorian Season three is that
there weren't any cameo scenes from House
Wren or Sabine in that final episode.
I didn't see any Clan
Ren banners during that,
but I'm assuming that they would have been
there as well to this is a much longer
scene of a soldier against throngs
HK droids in the Jedi Inquisitor.
Still a lot of people wondering,
this is just going to be Ezra underneath
the armor.
There's going to be some huge twist
because it seems like it's a male
and it's much taller
and she has another fight with it
in that forest.
the weird thing
about the inquisitor fights
if it's not a flashback
is that the inquisitorial?
It didn't really exist
after the events of the original trilogy.
So you wonder why.
Why is this Inquisitor
still wearing the Inquisitor armor?
when they're in a soldier ship,
they almost wind up running
into one of the space whales,
one of the pergolas,
there was a brief cameo scene
from the Pergolas at the beginning
of the Mandalorian series with Grogu
seeing them in hyperspace,
one of the reasons why they're so big,
metaphorically and literally during
the Ahsoka series
is because there was a big arc
with the Pergolas
during Star Wars rebels early on.
And then at the end of the series,
the space wheels are what took Ezra
and Thrawn fleet into the unknown regions.
They're meant to be highly intelligent
and Ezra Bridger is kind of
like they're friends.
That's why they helped him out.
At the end of Star Wars Rebels
We get the full on shot of Thrawn.
I know people are wondering
about the special effects.
They might tune it up a little bit.
There were some potato quality
versions of him that leaked out earlier.
but it is Lawrence
MIKKELSON coming back to do the character
he did the voice during Star Wars rebels.
He did say he had to tune his voice
just a little bit for live action
because the animated version
of his character
just sounded a little too singsong
when he did that in live action,
it seems like a bunch of the characters
are fighting in this forest here
There we get another big info bomb,
another big reveal Baylan Skoll, new
Anakin Skywalker
before Order 66 and Revenge of the Sith
when he fell to the dark side.
Remember Baylan Skoll used to be a Jedi
that just survived Order 66.
So it sounds like he might have
a little bit of a beef against Anakin
And maybe he's made his peace with that.
but I do like the idea that he knew
who Ahsoka
was immediately on seeing her like, Oh,
yeah, you're clearly in against Padawan.
He talked about you all the time.
then we get a longer scene of that Jedi
Temple scene
from the beginning of the trilogy
with the so-called running.
It seems like Thrawn tries to blow it up
during their fight here, or Thrawn's
people try to blow it up.
we get another new scene of David
Tennant's Jedi Droid back.
Dave Filoni confirmed it is the same one
from Star Wars the Clone Wars.
He's over a thousand years old.
He he knew most of the modern Jedi
for the past thousand years or so,
including Master Yoda,
when he would have been a Padawan to
when he would have been grogu
sized in the make another big Star Wars
rebels call back when Hera says once
a rebel, always a rebel.
Now obviously
it's a rebel alliance reference to
because they were all part
of the rebel alliance.
but because the Ahsoka series
is meant to be kind of like a live action
Star Wars Rebels Season five.
It's more of a star Wars rebels reference
and even though we don't see him
anywhere in the trailer here
Jason here is son with Kanan
is supposed to be part of the series too.
He's also for sensitive
but there's so many new scenes.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
and I'll do more bonus
videos as we get more footage
in the next couple of weeks.
there's a bunch of stuff happening
this week.
There's a new blue beetle trail
that's dropping.
I'll try to do a video for that
soon in my full secret Invasion
episode for video we'll post on Wednesday,
so be sure to enable alerts
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 teaser with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in his full on yellow costume
from the comics.
And click here
for all my other Ahsoka trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!